If nothing else,
it's a story that we would've needed to hear when we were younger.
Given the nature of our story,
I know the words that inevitably accompany it --
victim, rapist --
and labels are a way to organize concepts,
but they can also be dehumanizing in their connotations.
Once someone's been deemed a victim,
it's that much easier to file them away as someone damaged,
dishonored,
less than.
And likewise, once someone has been branded a rapist,
it's that much easier to call him a monster --
inhuman.
But how will we understand what it is in human societies
that produces violence
if we refuse to recognize the humanity of those who commit it?
And how --
(Applause)
And how can we empower survivors if we're making them feel less than?
How can we discuss solutions to one of the biggest threats
to the lives of women and children around the world,
if the very words we use are part of the problem?
TS: From what I've now learnt,
my actions that night in 1996 were a self-centered taking.
I felt deserving of Thordis's body.
I've had primarily positive social influences
and examples of equitable behavior around me.
But on that occasion,
I chose to draw upon the negative ones.
The ones that see women as having less intrinsic worth,
and of men having some unspoken and symbolic claim to their bodies.
These influences I speak of are external to me, though.
And it was only me in that room making choices,
nobody else.
When you own something
and really square up to your culpability,
I do think a surprising thing can happen.
It's what I call a paradox of ownership.
I thought I'd buckle under the weight of responsibility.
I thought my certificate of humanity would be burnt.
Instead, I was offered to really own what I did,
and found that it didn't possess the entirety of who I am.
Put simply,
something you've done doesn't have to constitute the sum of who you are.
The noise in my head abated.
The indulgent self-pity was starved of oxygen,
and it was replaced with the clean air of acceptance --
an acceptance that I did hurt this wonderful person standing next to me;
an acceptance that I am part of a large and shockingly everyday grouping of men
who have been sexually violent toward their partners.
Don't underestimate the power of words.
Saying to Thordis that I raped her changed my accord with myself,
as well as with her.
But most importantly,
the blame transferred from Thordis to me.
Far too often,
the responsibility is attributed to female survivors of sexual violence,
and not to the males who enact it.
Far too often,
the denial and running leaves all parties at a great distance from the truth.
There's definitely a public conversation happening now,
and like a lot of people,
we're heartened that there's less retreating
from this difficult but important discussion.
I feel a real responsibility to add our voices to it.
TE: What we did is not a formula that we're prescribing for others.
Nobody has the right to tell anyone else how to handle their deepest pain
or their greatest error.
Breaking your silence is never easy,
and depending on where you are in the world,
it can even be deadly to speak out about rape.
I realize that even the most traumatic event of my life
is still a testament to my privilege,
because I can talk about it without getting ostracized,
or even killed.
But with that privilege of having a voice
comes the responsibility of using it.
That's the least I owe my fellow survivors who can't.
The story we've just relayed is unique,
and yet it is so common with sexual violence being a global pandemic.
But it doesn't have to be that way.
One of the things that I found useful on my own healing journey
is educating myself about sexual violence.
And as a result, I've been reading, writing
and speaking about this issue for over a decade now,
going to conferences around the world.
And in my experience,
the attendees of such events are almost exclusively women.
But it's about time that we stop treating sexual violence as a women's issue.
(Applause)
A majority of sexual violence against women and men
is perpetrated by men.
And yet their voices are sorely underrepresented in this discussion.
But all of us are needed here.
Just imagine all the suffering we could alleviate
if we dared to face this issue together.
Thank you.
(Applause)